by the way if we did live by the idea to
boycott everything that supports the
zionists we might as well live in caves
it won't be a life look at what he's
saying live your life you can live your
life you can sleep at night I would love
to see you face to
face just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you remind us download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends as you guys may know Farris
hamadi whatever his name is for that
matter this person who has no atom
weight of Shame with his white beard who
tells us that you know boycotting is
Haram and you shouldn't B and what to
use blah blah blah laughing at the
matter like it's a joke but if it's his
same if it was his own child now he's
got his little uh student this guy who's
on Tik Tok what's his name fa faceless
nameless people that's what they are
they have no name I don't even want to
mention his name I don't even want to
know his name yeah I was going to do a
video about this guy long time ago yeah
okay the way he's holding his camera
anytime he's doing a video like this I
don't know he's trying to look hard or
something yeah I SW on the r of the Caba
if I came face to face with you I will
say exactly what I'm saying to your face
and this is what I'm going to say I'm
going to fall into backbiting cuz I
don't want to give my good deeds to
people like you yeah your faris's little
uh uh whatever you want to call it okay
this is what he had to say I mean it's
going to boil your blood these people
are coldhearted individuals okay let's
watch the video I want to watch the
video bro let's let's let's watch the
video for oursel and they're tell us
that boycott doesn't work here so as it
stands Coca-Cola has Hal ingredients
therefore it's Hal for Muslims to
consume by the way if we did live by the
idea to boycott everything that supports
Z
we might as well live in caves it won't
be a life so inshallah just live your
life and let the scholars declare what
is and what Isam so just live your life
who cares what what what life what life
would you live what is the purpose of
that life that the um is bleeding and
you're kicking it well it's down when
people are crying in their homes because
they're seeing their brothers and
sisters being slaughtered and this ounce
of thing that they can do because like
the brothers have said we're not going
be responsible for the results yeah the
means that's what we have control with
and the small actions Allah doesn't want
results Allah wants you to try yes there
were many ibraim Alam did he see the um
flock into Mecca no but he that thank
you Allah doesn't want the result he
wants to see how much you're trying do
you not have atwe of sh bro bro bro if
this person was alive at the time of
ibraim alisam when he was calling the
people just live your life
yeah why are you calling people why you
calling people what's the point what's
the point what's going to happen shame
on you man the only say shame on you you
have there are pictures of bodies of
babies blown into pieces you Shameless
man yeah you Shameless man yeah you're
trying to look hard on camera holding
the camera in a certain angle you know
make your shoulders look big uh uh big
or something like that you're a weak man
you are a weak man you boil my blood
okay you boil my blood how dare you the
least we can do is Boycott let me tell
you something yes can we boycott every
damn product no is it possible yes and
let me tell you something I believe
boycotting is very important there are
things that I did not know that were
things that I bought like Costa Coffee
bro I didn't know it was owned by
Coca-Cola bro I found out bro I was
thinking to myself what's more important
me drinking Costa Coffee me I don't
drink Coke anyways I don't like fiz
drinks for that matter okay I don't
really have them yeah I usually used to
drink appetizer and I found out that
it's owned by Coca-Cola yeah did I say
to myself oh but you know but I like
appetizer with my drink what tastes
better to me than any drink is the fact
that I am hitting their pockets that
tastes sweeter than any drink I can
drink and instead of coming here and
giving Solutions you know what brothers
it's hard to boycott all products let's
start gradually look at what he seeing
live your life you can live your life
you can sleep at night yes that there
are thousands and millions of Muslims
Muslim woman and Muslim men who are
crying who are disturbed by what's
happening to our brothers and sisters in
Palestine while you're sitting in U I
don't know where he is where you are
living it large it's all calm putting a
camera out I would love to see you face
to face not that I'm saying I'm going to
do anything to you I would love to see
you face to face man and to ask you what
kind of a heart do you have that you can
casually say live your life you can
listen let me tell you something you and
FIS can live your life the um don't need
you ya Abbi move on yes this um is an um
of action boycots have been working so
much bro I was going to say in what's in
Morocco bro tell me H&M and Starbucks
have left and we're seeing in many
countries many places these places are
desolate the umah is Raising awareness
now you might see certain Brothers in
certain places that doesn't mean that
you name and shame them different people
are boycotting different companies and
different
organizations however boycott whatever
is in your means and what's practical to
you some brothers and sisters they may
have certain brands around them they
might not be able to venture very far
however again this is something that you
can do with whatever capacity that you
can now if a person doesn't want to do
it it's not a matter of we're not
getting into Halal or Haram but at least
keep your mouth closed at least don't
mock yeah at least don't mock the people
that are doing something exactly shut
your mouth look me I Adidas there
there's a website that mam sent me which
shows you all the list yeah bro I saw
Adidas there do you think I'm going
about Adas again I'm not you know why
because my luxury I don't give a damn
Aki well I stayed away from Nik because
of the whole um they were they wrote
Allah's name and the U underneath the
trainers Etc okay well I I will go back
to Nik but if Israel is supporting is
Israel ad supporting Israel bro I've
already started certain things I'm not
seeing this to Big myself up I'm doing
Coca-Cola I drink anyway appetizer
stopped Costa Coffee stopped when I
found out yeah Adidas which I verified
if it's true and I think it is I'm not
wearing Adidas anymore now the clothes
that I have am I going to burn them no
but what I'm going to do is from now on
Adidas is done we're not telling you go
and burn the stuff that you have you
have Intel by the way Intel HB these
laptops we're not seeing throw them if
you got the product use that tool cuz
you already bought it use that tool to
Aid the Palestinians you get what I'm
trying to say but we're seeing moving on
from now onwards okay hey boycott as
much as you can yeah as much as you can
don't mock the people that are doing
something because bro people are going
to go crazy and this is a way because
they are making BDS boycott um the
there's a organization called BDS in
America you actually lose companies
actually lose out because Insurance more
Insurance gets
rejected your if your house got flooded
Insurance you get rejected if you
boycott Israel bro it is hurting them
carry on brothers and sisters ignore
individuals like this I've been very
careful because you know what I hate
this brother for the sake of Allah of
what he said Andis but you notice one
thing I don't speak it or call them
names because the last person I want to
give my goodies on is people that I
don't like so I'm going to refrain from
that for the sake of Allah subh I ask
Allah subh to guide you people or deal
with you individuals inshallah shame on
you ignore these people and boycott
these people boycott these individuals
inshallah and boycott the the products
that support the killing of our brothers
and sisters and we will do everything in
our power and soon in on my Channel or a
separate Channel I'm going to be heavily
involving myself in the boycott movement
inshallah and just so everybody knows no
I do not commit suicide so if you find
myself dead for that matter just know I
didn't kill myself yeah I'm heavily
going to be emphasizing the issue of
boycotting and I'm going to do a product
at a time maybe three products a month
where I will go to the stores myself and
I will tell you how they connected to
Israel inshallah till next time brother
sisters may Allah bless you insh
um boyot is working in Morocco M was it
McDonald's no H&M it was Starbucks H&M
absolutely closed down and we're going
to make sure they all close down one by
one okay so in the meantime let certain
individuals live their life while we
inshallah do at least stand in front of
Allah we live our life and the hair
after insh as well we live our life for
our Palestinian brother and sister
inah